the man who has for years led a parallel
government in Libya now calls on all
Libyans to rise up against what he
described as a looming Turkish invasion
well I do look at and at how the enemy
has announced war he has advertised
aggression and decided to invade our
nation he better stay watchful they're
friendly Turkish people which had tied
to us in Brotherhood in Islam must stand
in the face of this deranged gambler who
is leading his army into ruin
now where's the HEPA barrel along Mattel
arrabiata capita we address our speech
to the whole Arab world to its people
and armies and leaders to its youth and
elderly saying that a national war is
being fueled by this terrain
turkish sultan throughout the whole
region targeting the Arab identity from
its West to its East Khalifa Haftar
self-declared Libyan National Army has
been fighting to take control of Tripoli
since April more than 20 rockets hit
civilian areas of Tripoli shortly after
his speech Hefner is backed by turkeys
regional rivals Saudi Arabia Egypt and
the United Arab Emirates Turkey is
determined to support the UN backed
government defending the Libyan capital
Turkey's Parliament approved the
deployment of troops to Libya last week
after the GNA asked for military support
but there are still no confirmed details
on timing troop numbers or what role
they'll take
in a statement the UN secretary-general
Antonio Guterres said he wants an
immediate ceasefire and a return to
political dialogue by all parties but
even the un-backed government seems to
have lost faith in the UN's efforts on
the ground one senior GNA leader told
Libyan TV his government no longer
relies on the UN mission in Tripoli Zane
bus Ravi al-jazeera well in Tripoli Al
Jazeera's Mahmoud Abdul Wahid says
people are afraid of further retaliation
from half tarz forces there is a state
of panic a state of anger among
civilians especially in the vicinity of
a mighty airport that's the area that
was targeted by rockets launched by half
those forces
that's according to the government of
national Accord
and the transportation minister at the
government of national Accord says that
20 rockets landed in the vicinity and
inside the airport of MIT killing one
civilian and injuring a number of other
civilians the outcome of the recent
attack is the Aviation hold at MIT
Airport and also schools have have have
been suspended in Fukushima neighborhood
deaths the area in the vicinity of MIT
airport if this is not the first time
this area has been hit by Hefner's
forces it has been especially mighty get
a pot has been had dozens of times by
half those forces since they launched
the military campaign to care to capture
Tripoli back in April